♪ ♪
>> Sean: NOW THE MEDIA MOB'S
SHAMELESS MALPRACTICE ON FULL
DISPLAY AGAIN TONIGHT IS THE
MAJOR SUNDAY SHOWS, GUESS WHAT.
A LARGELY IGNORED THE
ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT LAST WEEK
AGAINST JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
THAT MEANS ABC, CBS,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" BARELY
COVER THE STORY.
EVEN PROMPTING SCORN FROM HBO'S
BILL MAHER.
HARDLY A CONSERVATIVE, TAKE A
LOOK.
IF >> YORK TIMES BURIED THIS.
IF THIS HAD BEEN A LIBERAL
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE THAT
SOMEONE CAME TO KILL THEM IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN ON THE FRONT
PAGE.
THAT'S WHAT'S SO DISAPPOINTING
ABOUT "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THEY WEAR THEIR BIAS ON THE
SLEEVES AND IF IT'S NOT PART OF
SOMETHING THAT FEEDS OUR
NARRATIVE, [BLEEP] IT.
>> Sean: KAYLEIGH McENANY
AND MIKE HUCKABEE ABOUT TO BE
DISPLACED AS THE FORMER BEST
GOVERNOR OF ARKANSAS AS HIS
DAUGHTER I EXPECT WILL WIN THE
RACE HANDILY.
LET ME START WITH YOU, THIS IS A
BIG STORY.
AN ASSASSINATION PLOT AGAINST A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
THEN WE'VE GOT THE APPROVAL OF
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE,
JEN PSAKI, AND CHUCK SCHUMER
THREATENING ON THE STEPS OF THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT.
THEY SEEM OKAY WITH THAT.
WE ARE FINE AS LONG AS THEY ARE
PEACEFUL.
IF I START GIVING OUT THE
ADDRESSES OF LIBERALS THAT I
DON'T LIKE AND SOMETHING
HAPPENS, DO YOU THINK I'M GOING
TO BE THE ONE THAT GETS BLAMED
FOR IT?
I WOULD THINK SO.
>> I WOULD THINK SO, THAT'S
CALLED DOXXING AND BLAME TO
100%.
THE REASON THE MEDIA IS IGNORING
IT IS BECAUSE A WAY, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS IGNORING IT.
HIS PRESS SECRETARY PUT OUT A
STATEMENT, BUT WHERE'S
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S VOICE ON THIS?
IT'S BEEN ALMOST SEVEN DAYS.
THE PRESS SECRETARY WENT OUT
THERE ERRONEOUSLY TODAY AND SAID
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF CONDEMNED
TO THIS.
HE HAS NOT CONDEMNED THAT.
THERE WILL BE A MINI REVOLUTION.
THERE ARE SUCH A DOUBLE STANDARD
AND WHEN I WAS AT THE PODIUM AND
I'M SURE GOVERNOR HUCKABEE
KNOWS, WE WERE ASKED TO CONDEMN
EVERY SINGLE EPISODE OF VIOLENCE
BIG, SMALL, WHATEVER EVEN IF IT
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
SO MUCH SO I HAD AN ENTIRE TAB
IN MY BINDER CALLED VIOLENCE
THAT WAS PAGES AND PAGES OF THE
TIMES THAT TRUMP CONDEMNED.
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE IS A
DIFFERENT STANDARD.
JOE CAN BE SILENT AND BY THE
WAY, 13 PRO-LIFE FACILITIES HAVE
BEEN EITHER FIREBOMBED OR
VANDALIZED ALONGSIDE.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, THAT'S
GOTTEN VERY LITTLE COVERAGE
ALSO.
IT GOVERNOR, TAKE ON IT?
UNDER NO CIRCUMSTANCES WOULD I
EVER PUT ANYBODY'S ADDRESS OUT
PUBLICLY SO PEOPLE WOULD KNOW
WHERE IT IS, DOXXING AS THEY
CALL IT.
OR ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO PROTEST
IN FRONT OF THE HOME OF A
JUSTICE.
IT DOES RAISE ISSUES REGARDING
THE LAW.
ARE THEY TRYING TO INTIMIDATE,
HARASS, JUSTICES IN DEVOTING A
CERTAIN WAY?
IT CERTAINLY SEEMS LIKE THAT TO
ME.
>> ITS DOMESTIC TERRORISM PEER
AND SIMPLE.
IT'S TRYING TO SCARE PEOPLE INTO
A DIFFERENT BEHAVIOR THAN YOU
EXPECT THEM TO DO.
CAN I JUST SAY, DO YOU KNOW THAT
THERE'S ONE THING THAT'S WORSE
THAN NOT ENFORCING THE LAW?
BY THE WAY, IT'S AGAINST FEDERAL
LAW TO GO TO THE HOME OF THE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE AND
PROTEST.
IF IT'S THE FEDERAL LAW.
IT I DON'T CARE WHAT
MERRICK GARLAND SAYS, HE'S DOING
A LOT OF THINGS BUT HE'S NOT
ENFORCING THE LAW.
THERE'S SOMETHING WORSE THAN NOT
IF THAT'S ONLY ENFORCING THE LAW
AGAINST YOUR POLITICAL ENEMIES.
THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY DISTURBING,
THAT WE SEE.
IF PETER NAVARRO ARRESTED,
STRIP-SEARCHED, PUT IN
HANDCUFFS AND AN AIRPORT.
ERIC HOLDER DOESN'T.
YOU CONSTANTLY SEE A DIFFERENT
SET OF RULES THAT ARE BEING
APPLIED TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONSERVATIVE VERSUS PEOPLE ON
THE FAR LEFT AND WHO ARE DOING
JUST ILLEGAL THINGS IN
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES HOMES.
>> Sean: WE'VE BEEN WATCHING
AND UNFOLD FOR A LONG TIME.
WE DON'T HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW.
WE DON'T HAVE EQUAL APPLICATION
OF THE LAW.
THAT NOW IS A FACT AND WE SAW
THAT.
TALK ABOUT "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
AND IGNORING OF THIS CASE.
FOR THREE LONG YEARS, THEY NEED
TO GIVE BACK AND THEY LIED ABOUT
TRUMP RUSSIA COLLUSION WHICH IS
NONE OF IT TRUE.
THEY WERE NEVER HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THAT PART EITHER.
IT YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THE LAW
PART.
IT IS AGAINST THE LAW TO HARASS
OR INTIMIDATE A JUSTICE.
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO START
DEMANDING THAT THE LAW BE NOT
ONLY ENFORCED, BUT ENFORCED
EQUALLY REGARDLESS OF SOMEONE'S
POLITICAL VIEW.
ALL THE PEOPLE ARRESTED AFTER
JANUARY 6, YOU CALLED FOR THEM
TO SUFFER THE FULL JUDGMENT OF
THE LAW IF THEY HURT SOMEONE OR
VANDALIZED.
IF EVERY OTHER CONSERVATIVE I
KNOW DID THE SAME THING.
IF WE BELIEVE IN TRUE LAW AND
ORDER.
WE DO NOT HEAR THAT FROM THE
LEFT.
YES, WE HAVE VIOLENT THREATS
AGAINST JUSTICE KAVANAUGH, HAVE
AGAINST AMY CONEY BARRETT'S, AND
WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN AGAINST
STEVE SCALISE WHO WAS ALMOST
KILLED BY AN ASSASSIN'S BULLET.
THE ATTACK BY A CRAZY GUY
AGAINST HIS OWN NEIGHBOR
RAND PAUL.
>> Sean: ALL THE ATTENTION TO
JANUARY 6TH, THAT WAS ONE RIOT.
I CONDEMNED IT REAL-TIME ON
RADIO AND THAT NIGHT ON TV.
WE ARE ALL CONSISTENT.
BUT I ALSO CONDEMN ALL 574 RIOTS
IN THE SUMMER OF 2020.
DOZENS DIED, THOUSANDS OF COPS
INJURED TO COME UP BILLIONS IN.
WE'VE GOT ALL THE VIDEO EVIDENCE
HE WOULD EVER WANT TO ARREST
EVERY ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE.
YET FROM WHAT I'VE HEARD IN MOST
OF THE CITIES WHERE IT HAPPENED,
NOBODY'S BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT GOES TO GOVERNOR HUCKABEE'S
POINT.
>> EXACTLY.
IN FACT IN PORTLAND AND I
REMEMBER THIS BECAUSE I FOLLOW
THE NEWS EACH AND EVERY NIGHT.
AT THE PODIUM AT THE TIME, THEY
WERE LOCKED IN A COURT HOUSE.
YOU HAD RIOTERS ATTEMPTING TO
BURN THOSE OFFICERS ALIVE.
THEY WERE FEDERAL OFFICERS
INSIDE THE COURTHOUSE.
AS IT TURNS OUT, THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE UNDER MERRICK GARLAND
DROPPED ONE-THIRD OF THE CASES
AGAINST THE PORTLAND RIOTERS.
WHERE IS THAT JUSTICE FOR THEM?
WHERE'S THE JUSTICE BY THE
DOZENS AS YOU MENTION WHO WERE
KILLED AND MANY MORE INJURED.
DAVID DORAN, THE OFFICER WHO WE
ALL KNOW AND LOVE WE COVERED HIS
STORY WHO LOST HIS LIFE AMID THE
RIOTS.
THERE MUST BE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
THERE IS NO REASON TO DROP A
THIRD OF CASES AGAINST THE
PORTLAND RIOTERS.
>> Sean: DON'T FORGET SHE'S ON
"OUTNUMBERED THE" EVERY DAY.
WHEN WE COME BACK, THREE
PENNSYLVANIA PARENTS NOW ARE
TAKING LEGAL ACTION TO STOP
TRANSGENDER RELATED LESSONS AT
THEIR KIDS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
AT PETE HEGSETH HAS WRITTEN A
BOOK DETAILING HOW YOU CAN
PROTECT YOUR KIDS FRO